[Music]
new at 11 o'clock as the pandemic
continues to impact our local economy a
lot of
people across las vegas are struggling
just to find food
but there are more options opening up
thanks for joining us i'm denise feldes
and i'm brian loft is something many of
us don't consider a good amount of those
people that have food allergies or
sensitivities
that's why one las vegas woman wants to
help those with specialized diets stay
healthy
our sasha loftis takes us inside the las
vegan food bank
meredith spriggs knows what it's like to
live with food allergies
there was just so much that i couldn't
eat all the time she has to avoid things
like gluten soy
and dairy but when she relied on others
to eat
the problem became unbearable things
that people don't think about
there are people in the homeless
population that have
have food sensitivities meredith is back
on her feet now
but says many others are in similar
situations
especially as the kovid 19 pandemic
cripples
our local economy the goal is to help
people we're trying to feed people
that's where the lost vegan food bank
comes in
donating meals to those who are vegan
vegetarian
and gluten-free that there's so much
demand for vegan food boxes i was really
surprised
and now i'm like we need to ramp it up
we need to do more
after just a few weeks the demand has
exploded
as many who are struggling can find
nutritious meals tailored to their
dietary restrictions
to have an option that is something good
and nutritious it sounds amazing it's an
opportunity meredith calls both
important and powerful and she urges
others to recognize the true benefit it
brings
to give give them choices i think that's
a gift sasha loftis
8 news now the las vegas food bank is
accepting applications for its next
distribution which is coming up in a
couple weeks
they're also looking for donations and
volunteers so if you need help or you
would like to help
we do have more information for you on
our website brian